what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so the Drowned is one of the
coolest stories from dark nights metal
all these one shots are so amazing in
terms of like giving us these evil
versions of Batman so the cool thing
about this is that this Center is on
what's actually Batwoman and it's a
person by the name of Brice Wayne and so
it's kind of interesting because what
this does is it initially picks up with
the idea that Brice was in a
relationship with a person named
Sylvester Kyle now we're not explicitly
told who's Sylvester Kyle is we're just
kind of told that this person was the
love interest of Brice Wayne at the time
but unlike the other you know one-shots
that we've seen so far this one actually
picks up after Bryce has already arrived
in the main DC Universe I want them to
keep in mind is all of these one shots
spin out of Dark Knight's metal number
two which is one of the things that
we're gonna reference once we cover that
story but the origin story is still
standalone but her arriving in MC Bay
which is basically one of the home bases
of operations of Arthur Currie of
Aquaman leads her into direct conflict
with Aquaman and with Meerut now we will
get the whole backstory but one thing
that I want to talk about here for a
second is the nature of amnesty Bay when
it comes to the Aquaman mythos there is
Atlantis and then there's amnesty Bay
Atlantis is the kingdom of Atlantis it's
basically Aquaman's birthright for the
most part in the sense that he was born
as the heir to Atlantis itself however
he was raised in amnesty Bay and that's
why he has this sort of dichotomy
between a loyalty to the Justice League
and somewhat to the protection of the
world overall but loyalty to Atlantis
because for him it's very much like Thor
Thor is like okay look yes I'm an
Avenger yadda yadda yadda but Asgard
first everything else second if it comes
down to it I will abandon earth and I
will go only to Asgard and rule as king
because that's my job that's what I do
first Aquaman's much the same way the
other half of that is that Aquaman will
protect both with an absolute fury you
know bow be tied the poor soul who shows
up in Atlantis starting trouble but the
whole backstory to this comes by way of
the explanation of Brice Wayne herself
in the sense that somewhere along the
line the various metahumans on earth
negative eleven and her own reality in
the dark multiverse somewhere along the
line they had killed Sylvester Kyle now
we don't know why we were kind of left
to believe maybe that they were
criminals or something along those lines
because the implication is that Bryce is
Batwoman was a crime fighter she fought
bad guys and so the implication
is that in this scenario Sylvester was
killed by some rogue Medes and in her
vengeance and in her morning she killed
everyone and so it's basically the
Batman comparison Bruce Wayne lost his
parents she lost her husband and so it's
cool to see those two things go
alongside each other because it shows
the nature of grief itself now the other
half of this is following the death of
Sylvester in the the deaths of all these
many humans at the hands of Brice
herself about eighteen months after this
had happened acqua woman had effectively
just shown out all the metahumans are
dead we want to have peace talks we want
to come to peace with the service world
itself now again this is another aspect
that we're not really given in the main
DC Universe Atlanteans aren't really
like xenophobic so much as they are
retreat us in the sense of they're
basically like you stay away we stay
away everything will be fine
but for bryce because of the fact that
she had experienced such a traumatic
loss much like batman who doesn't trust
anybody but himself
she doesn't trust anybody but herself
and in her mind she believed that
atlantis was pulling a ruse that
Atlantis had seen the deaths of all the
metahumans and then said harken alas no
one can protect the surface from us if
we choose to invade but if we just jump
in and immediately start going to war
there'll be casualties on both sides so
we'll play a diplomatic at first and
then when they're at their weakest we'll
conquer them Bryce believed that was the
case and so in her anger ultimately the
peace talks fell to pieces and then
Bryce chose the surface world and waged
war against Atlantis and in doing so
killed aqua woman with her own Trident
now following this because of the fact
that the response of the Atlanteans to
the death of their queen was to drown
the entirety of Gotham City this push
Bryce even further and so I hope you
guys are starting to see a pattern here
this scenario where Bryce lost someone
she cared about to one or more
metahumans in response in her wrath and
in her anger and in her her her mourning
she killed them all this in turn led to
Atlantis stepping in and saying let's
have peace talks the peace talks fell
apart and again in her just altered
state of mind not rationally thinking
she does waged war against everybody and
so ultimately this leads to her
modifying her body on the genetic level
giving yourself all kinds of alterations
basically making yourself an Atlantian
but in turn modifying her existing
abilities for example when it comes to
the the concept of Batman we're largely
left to believe that he's just a really
really good fighter I mean that's really
what Batman is he's a normal guy that's
just really good at fighting he knows
all these different martial arts things
like that with Bryce we're left to
believe that's the same way we're just
kind of left to believe that she's just
a woman who's really capable making
these modifications to her body means
she's taking the wort directly to
Atlantis and when she does she has to be
able to fight on their battlefield it's
the perfect complement to Sun Tzu's the
art of war if you have to wage a war
wage a war on your terms but if you have
to wage a war on their terms be prepared
and that's exactly what she does she
basically starts modifying your body
with these genetic modifications she
gives herself the ability to breathe on
their water she can move faster than any
of the Atlanteans she's pushed herself
to the absolute brink and so when the
time comes not only was she able to wage
war against Atlantis and basically kill
all the Atlanteans she had done so with
the help of what's called the dead water
basically her own
ethically modified forces that can in
turn serve on her behalf
now the implication here and the way
this seems to be pointed is that
somewhere along the line because she had
basically started capturing forces
bolstering her numbers and then
modifying them genetically were not
explicitly told that but it looks like
these are just twisted versions of
Atlanteans and so the result is that she
basically used Atlanteans assuming that
she did any way to destroy Atlanteans
ultimately killing off the entire
Atlantic community and then taking up
residence in Atlantis herself following
this she drowned the entire world killed
everybody on earth just destroyed
everybody on earth is absolutely bonkers
in terms of how it comes out and so in
response to this should there have been
anybody out there who was wayward
anybody out there who was looking for
solace she put up a beacon in the sky to
show them where to go now this gets into
the true and really the terrifying
nature of Brice herself in the sense
that that beacon was not done for
altruistic purposes she did that so that
anybody who came across her path they
would be added to her roster of soldiers
they would become another member of her
army they would be genetically modified
and they would be transformed into one
of her own but in the middle of all this
and at some point later on down the line
the beacon suddenly went off and when it
did she was met with the man who last
now the man who lasts in my opinion is
one of the most anticipated origin
stories in all of dark knights medal I
am so looking forward to that and I
think a lot of people are like a lot of
people are really excited for the man
who last and there's so many theories
because the best theory I've seen so far
is that the man who last comes from a
universe where Batman actually killed
the Joker during the events of The
Killing Joke and then Batman became the
Joker that's the best theory that I've
heard I think it's the most popular one
going around the internet right now but
you know very rarely do I ever see a
theory take hold like this I saw it with
mr. oz saw it with the Watchmen BC
rebirth is just setting the world on
fire with the stories they're writing
Jesus Christ it's amazing but the fact
remains here with regards to Bryce's
showing up and facing off against
Aquaman and Mira you have Mira with her
you know Aqua Kinesis the ability to
manipulate water using her mind but it's
almost like the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet
versus Thanos with the heart of the
universe concept in the sense that with
the Infinity Gauntlet Thanos was
manipulating the universe itself with
the heart of the universe he was the
universe and that's exactly what's
happening here where Mira is able
- you know psychically manipulate the
water rice is the water like she just
controls this it's it's like an arm or a
leg it's an inherent part of who she is
now all this is designed to do is
basically say that Bryce's control over
water is stronger than mirrors control
over water that's all that means
I mean it doesn't mean the price is
actually made of water it just means
that her control is far more powerful
than been mirrors is but the
significance of this is that it gives us
a character that overpowers both Aquaman
and Meera and this is a big deal because
remember when it comes to Aquaman he can
stand toe to toe to Superman I mean we
saw that in Aquaman rebirth like we saw
that in that first story he went toe to
toe with Superman and held his own so
it's not like Aquaman's just a really
strong guy who talks to fish not at all
this guy is a wrecking crew he's a
one-man army and so to have someone from
you know to have this Brice chick
genetically modified herself and then
show up and not only beat a guy who
amounts to an underwater version of
Superman and then crush his wife who
controls water is insane because it
means this person is not someone to be
trifled with not only that the idea of a
person becoming a dead water is
basically an action that's undertaken by
Brice herself when she physically
transforms the body of Meera now I would
argue this is not a permanent thing that
the process can most likely be reversed
especially if it's just an alteration to
the chemical structure of the body but
the fact remains Meera is effectively a
henchman of Brice now and that's how
this unfolds is because it leads to
Aquaman seeming to be the last man
standing in the face of Brice all her
dead water soldiers and Meera having
been transformed into one which leads as
it always does with these one shots with
dr. fate intervening now again dr. fade
is a character that predates dr. strange
by quite a bit but the characters are
effectively one of the same in terms of
how they function and what they do what
dr. fate is doing here is really more
akin to like what dr. strange was doing
during Infinity Gauntlet but the fact
remains that doctor fates basically
grabbing these various heroes who were
encountering these Dark Knights of
Barbados and then whisking them away to
a safe place so they can remaster their
forces and then go back into the
onslaught again to plan ahead and so
that's effectively what happens this
symbol is sent out into the sky by Bryce
in order to attract anybody who's either
curious or looking for some kind of
refuge of some sort and then ultimately
bolster her own army using those
individuals so again another
origin story another dark night cropping
out another character with an extreme
level of power who's basically able to
dominate some of the most powerful
heroes in DC Comics and so again it's
cool but with that being said guys if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]